- Hallo, Otto!
- Hallo, Thomas.
Schön, dich zu sehen.
Wie war der Urlaub?
Bestimmt total günstig, he?
Wir werden bald sehr groß, Otto …
größer als jede andere Zeitung in der Stadt.
Soziale Netzwerke, digitale
Versionen, Apps – und wir sind dabei!
Und für dich ist es dann auch besser.
Dann lesen mehr Frauen deine Anzeigen.
- Ich habe eine Bitte, Thomas.
- Ich weiß. Wie willst du
diesmal heißen? Jerôme? Rodrigo?
- Das ist es nicht …
- Wie soll ich dich in deiner nächsten
Kontaktanzeige beschreiben?
Der einfühlsamste Mann
der Welt sucht seine Erfüllung?
Total verständnisvoller,
charmanter als alle anderen Männer?
Oder lieber ein bisschen direkter?
Der Mann, vor dem Sie
Ihre Kinder warnen,
aber von dem Sie ganz
heimlich träumen?
- Thomas … Ich möchte
keine Kontaktanzeige mehr.
- Was? Wieso?
- Ich habe mich total verliebt, Thomas.
Und zwar echt.
Sie ist die tollste, lustigste Frau, die ich
in meinem Leben kennengelernt habe.
Und ich möchte, dass du mir hilfst,
sie nie mehr zu verlieren.
- Wir kennen uns jetzt seit
fünfzehn Jahren, Otto.
Seit zehn Jahren schalte ich
Kontaktanzeigen in meiner Zeitung für dich.
Den Gefallen tu ich dir
sehr gerne, mein Freund!